i had a good buddy on my uh two episodes
ago i love the guy i just genuinely love
my worst numbers right and coming out
the gate you don't want no bad number
right now you're like i want half a
million every episode right right yeah
it's like
but dude you told me you had vitali on
and that just tripped me out like uh you
said he's been sober for eight months
here's the thing uh yeah i'm i'm a
little biased i love this kid like i
want to see vitaly do great right
so i had him on my show he told me he's
been sober we had lots of talks leading
up to it and look it's controversial
sure but it also makes great podcasts
right of course everybody hating on him
right now also wants to hear it so it's
been a very successful episode but at
the same time i got to witness and i
think the viewers really did too a new
vitality eight months sober
the vitali we know couldn't sit for an
hour hour and a half and do this he
couldn't right he would be pooping on
your table or doing the helicopter right
he's just the craziest human i know and
i tell him that all the time i mean
isn't it
like i mean i i don't know but i just
kind of got this sense that
you went pg
that made sure you did the natural-born
pranksters movies together but kind of
about that time
like you went your own way and and it
felt like you kind of needed to distance
yourself from vitaly
we definitely went separate ways
mainly no reason whatsoever friendship
wise love the kid my whole
time i've known him love him it's it was
tough to watch him kind of
like like before like the big thing with
the arrest like it was like he
we were watching the wheels fall off and
it was tough you know and it makes sense
that you can't [ __ ] with the guy when
he's in self-destruct mode
yeah i definitely never uh
uh felt like i left this side in any
case but i certainly like went a
different direction you know i came back
to ohio and filmed with my kids and
right i couldn't keep up with the
i couldn't party anyway i was editing
every night right i don't remember you
ever partying i couldn't because i was
uploading every day and i was the editor
and the cameraman so it was like it was
also my excuse not to party and keep my
family strong it was like
11 o'clock at night gotta edit this
video man it's like but
it's so it's so interesting to hear you
say that that vlogging creating videos
like and keep my family strong in the
same sentence
like
disney
like how much stress does the constant
cameras and vlogging like
i think i think brittany and i just
talked about this recently i don't think
we went to bed together for almost three
years
because because i would edit till 3am
she would get the kids to bed she would
go to sleep and i would just
i was so
dedicated 100
to the time i wake up it's what i'm
filming and i also had to try to one-up
it every day i went as hard as i could
sure um to the time i just passed out on
the couch usually while i was uploading
it's not good for your
[ __ ] health
absolutely destroyed me you know what's
crazy i didn't know it until i stopped i
was like on a snowball but when i
stopped it took me
it really it aged me so hard man what do
you i don't see it man i'm furious i
don't know i'm working out hard like you
did at this age but i was like i'm
furious with how young you look at 39.
well i'll be honest brit shaved all the
grays off last night i was like they
glisten in the light man
yeah so i was like uh under the hat it's
it's terrible but i was like just enough
to cover the house yeah
i got a ton of grays and we're the same
age i think that clip was awesome but
not as awesome as my new book a hard
kick in the nuts what i've learned from
a lifetime of terrible decisions which
is out september 27th and if you
pre-order it right now you can get the
autographed copy so get on it man
pre-order my book it's not going to
waste your time because i'm proven dude
new york times best seller my first
book's five star rated on amazon and i
have no doubt this one will be two so
get the autographed copy right now by
pre-ordering it at stevo.com
yeah dude